[Music]
[Music]
whoa
hello everyone hi it's good to see you
my name is Ben and I'm here with Miguel
and Miguel what are we gonna be playing
we are playing the hot wheels DLC of
Forza horizon 3 yes and I'm going to be
basically Manning the chat talking to
you guys and feeding Miguel questions
you might have for him he has in fact
the person who reviewed the game when it
first came out mm-hm
ah it was a great it was a great
opportunity I I initially thought that
the someone on the Australia team would
have been calling dibs on reviewing this
given the setting but it would make a
lot of sense
uh no it turns out I had a really no one
to quote-unquote compete with for the
assignment oh man it just got from the
showroom it just jumps straight to the
hot wheels will take cinematic beautiful
dystopian future is this where we have
orange tracks everywhere and fantastic
cars to drive let's listen to this and
throw
some dinosaur Miguel in sign-off yes oh
man alright those are our intro bring
this back down if you guys need me to
adjust the volume at all for for
anything let me know - let's see if it's
all good fast travel it's right there
it's right next to like the the first
festival mm-hmm I like that he plans for
HDR option and PC version I wish I could
tell you uh dance school but I honestly
don't know I it's a play anywhere title
but I actually have not even installed
it on my PC uh which is kind of sad kind
of really into playing it on my xbox but
I'm sure there's something out there for
it let's see where'd it go okay
oh you're way up at the top yeah alright
you got it you got a bit of a drive so
we can kind of relax and and hang out
and chat a bit then in the fast travel
or you can just fast travel will pay the
money okay I was gonna have a wonderful
road trip with you and everyone else but
I guess not anymore
I like all they're still showing off
blizzard mountain though while you're
headed to the Hot Wheels track nothing
against Blizzard Mountain but I think to
be honest forgot that was there yeah
he's same but I mean the base game is so
good all in itself there's new when you
think you're almost done with it they
kindly double off and they're like do it
all again that's travel there - ok get
the game volume a little higher I can do
that for you I'm not gonna go too crazy
we could be louder - crank everything up
is what you're telling me unique at New
York see no I'm gonna pump it I'll pump
it up it is listen some sweet jams and
some cool times play on PC and 4k on
Ultra it's amazing I I believe that was
a Chris Chris Matthews I I don't have a
4k monitor I'm I'm still rockin at 1080p
that sweet sweet 1080p can pull you know
actually I one of with my friends
created one
the premier clubs you can join in this
game called only Coronas as a very still
accepting oh yeah it's open to anyone
you guys can join it's great
we have great times for you guys to try
to beat but we always do it for our boy
P W let's uh let's break up the game out
here a little bit okay I'm in I'm in
just as the cutscene ends okay is this a
mod uh it almost seems like it is it's
that crazy
did you actually like this pack is $20
for its with the season pass if you own
that ha which also includes blizzard
mountain and I think maybe some couple
like a couple of car packs I'm not
entirely up on I just bought the hundred
dollar version when it came out because
I just went real hard in it but yeah
good canonically speaking so in Forza
horizon 3 you're a driver who is running
this competition out in the middle of
Australia mm-hmm can you imagine the
pitch session for what is about to
happen he's like you guys know Hot
Wheels right I want those giant orange
tracks all over this this entire country
want to drive them I want to ramp I want
to fly and also I want life-sized
versions of my favorite cars make it
happen oh here we go imma turn this up
oh man oh that's such a nice effect when
parts of the car are leaking out of the
letterbox and right
good god I was gonna drop you in right
there no I'm gay
yeah it is is it open world and does it
got story like super crazy amaze story
says Stephen Sam uh so it's not crazy
like this what else right now uh but
it's it's still kind of grounded in
reality
but it's got kind of a progression where
you you are person running a festival
and as time goes on they're like boss
you've got some great fans but we need
to do something crazy to blow out of
water we're gonna have you race a train
or race a helicopter or just something
like that and that's kind of how crazy
it's gotten up until now and now we've
got this so oh goodness
yeah I know it's a great game it's a
great driving game if you're into
driving it's also kind of accessible
because it straddles that line of like
simulation in an arcade really well
there are a 141 roads in this DLC and
you can see every single one with your
eyes right now that's because they're
all bright orange talking over the duck
I'm very sorry that you're talking it's
like door I'm sorry that I'm talking
over here you're he's doing the same
commentary I am it's literally the same
thing but can you believe we put actual
dinosaurs on the track how many cars
does it have a faded question I hear it
I think this DLC has like it has a good
amount of cars but they're all like
actual hot wheels they didn't go like
there's not 20 or 30 maybe there's like
12 or 15 I don't know the exact number
taking random steps did the add more
optimization I actually looked at a
thing and I believe they did some
optimization for the PC version you're
literally going sideways right now I'm
ago like actually sideways if there was
a there's another nitro optimizer so I
think the way that nitro works is it's
on boost
like that okay all right I don't know if
there's an actual like button to
activate it but you're just a driver
right there yeah so there's there's
boosts there's jumps flaming hoops
dinosaurs is basically got everything
you'd ever want in an actual simulation
driving game I played up I played an
intro wonderful nice we'll get fantastic
I actually it's a kind of a weird thing
of mine to like want to get more people
to play Forza horizon does a funny story
my roommate a very picky game player he
he has never played a racing game before
Forza right like the original for
surprising horizon um yeah so he he
never played a racing game until the
first one and I sold him on it he's like
alright fine man I'll jump in on this
because you're recommending it so highly
and the boy now knows like cars by
looking at them and he hasn't missed a
single entry in the horizon series it's
a really good racing game for people who
were kind of on the fence about racing
games yeah this DLC is out today out
today my to answer question a couple
pages back my xbox tag is circle of vice
hmm it's an Eddie Izzard reference I see
mines philanthropy with a zero because
someone took the original name and I
like Metal Gear Solid 2 a lot to to
looks the anti metal your organization
in Metal Gear and mill your cell to is
called philanthropy and I'm not going to
start talking about Metal Gear because
this will turn into a medal your stream
faster and faster cars oh my gosh we'll
give out medals as qualifiers any
questions oh we're doing the medal
alright go on get out there look at all
the track everywhere oh I love it
put Speed Racer on this game I'd be in
sign it up oh wait I went back into the
audition
oops sorry well sometimes maybe you can
look at like the other cars they got in
there I think it might be a good a good
chance to kind of look at what they've
got to buy or what the customs I don't
know if you can customize these cars
is your classic Hot Wheels racers games
not updated it so you can't play I I
think there might be a way to force it
to update or maybe like just if you're
on xbox maybe hard resetting your xbox
or it'll happen though it'll happen and
it'll be a good time racing in in no
time at all answer that question not
mine I'm sorry Chuck what was your
question I missed it I'm I'm trying real
hard here I promise I care and I want to
talk to you I see your caps I got you
just just ask it one more time
Chuck tighten them I'll throw it out so
this is for Xbox and PC and it actually
is a play anywhere title so you can
actually kind of play it back and forth
with each other and it's kind of really
nice for that cop so he's gonna die I I
don't know what that means
but I sure yeah what am I gonna do oh I
think someone was saying that I talk
like I'm about to die which I'm not sure
what that means
I'd please elaborate and I'll get back
to you how much is the DLC it's trying
to go it yes yeah try the hard reset you
got it I hope it works for you if you
have the season passes this included
Chuck Titan yes it is as a person who
owns a season pass it is it is included
in it you're set to go all you got to do
is download it it's like a two and a
half quick download or something not too
big lesson thickness it means I
downloaded a lot of things yesterday
is it out in Europe also uh I hope let's
guess this so this is a good jam a plus
ps4 switch gameplay on neither this is
on the Xbox one will hold that but glad
the butts early in the morning I only
had half my coffee before I came in here
this is the Xbox one home entertainment
console Jan is asking us to show the map
well we could probably do that after
we're done doing the race thanks for
your patience what we can do that for
you we saw like a little bit of it
before we pick the race earlier but oh
I'm actually going to curious - just
doing a loop ah
also the the metal thing to not wear
like not only do you have to finish the
race but you have to like finish it to
get bronze you have to get first to
actually get the like silver tier and
then the gold tier is like getting first
and then also getting a certain number
of points
I noticed which I realize now we're
covering up with our camera but you know
it's okay I'll tell you right we're in
fourth out of 12 fourth out of 12 with
33% of the race completed so I am go I
am hopeful oh wait hold on a tour
tomorrow is throwing out that it's not
good in season passion at the expansion
pass that actually might be a thing oh
my god
your turbo dead now up let's see how far
back it said like a 12th position that's
cruel got eight if there are actually
two different passes that might actually
be a thing and I might be wrong I
double-check that not be a dealer
resident if if you go and check it out
on the store and you have one of the
passes it should be just say download
for you it is included in the expansion
past then I guess
get this on the switch I wish I could
get it on the switch guys real talk I
love the switch yes says the the
champion of our inaugural Mario Kart 8
deluxe tournament strict I did I did win
by one point one just one singular
primary exciting but you know it won't
be on the switch unfortunately yeah show
us the cool hot wheel cars we can check
that out in a bit - oh you got people
requesting to see the cars that are
included the map we'll get to in a bit
we just want to do it we wanted to erase
be the champ has it benefits
it's a host rather than half it's true
the only allow me to do racing games
though I have to continually show that
I'm able to handle of whatever games are
coming out and I'll eventually break out
any of those but yeah not included in
the car so the car pass I know it's not
in because the car pass is like
exclusive different there are three
passes for this video K what is even
happening trying to draft some clean
racing happening some speed happening
some drafting happening there it is that
slingshot is it on the ps1 no the ps1 is
very old now I suggest Oh second it's
maybe stepping up it's okay
second place is good you got you got to
finish you only fall off once there's
cool dinosaur here so that's a good time
the Ultimate Edition have all the stages
plus the hop ISM so I have whatever the
hundred dollar version is and I know
that it's included in that I can say
that much
I probably should have done some
research before we caught on here so I
can actually like throughout the facts I
know they're Hot Wheels cars you know
you're welcome to look it up it's true
but I'm afraid to touch anything on the
streaming computer ok is this GTA no
Matt B it's not GTA but I understand how
you could kind of get get confused by it
for a lot of cars flying around oh but
I'm pretty sure you won't be forgetting
that anytime soon you're right I won't
I won't be forgetting these metals at
all uh yeah I'm actually really excited
about the fact that this is very much
like a TrackMania kind of thing because
I I got on the track mania bus kind of
late but was it TrackMania to canyon was
the one I really dug into but I like the
crazy like unrealistic stadium driving
the trick things I don't know what to
classify that as here's our map by the
way so it's a pretty sizable a spiral
summit I bet you can do some cool
drifting there the title teeth um real
city are we can we go to thrill City yes
we can let's do that thank you so much
mm-hmm
the framerate is bad is it the game or
the stream it's not the game it might be
the stream though I know that our stream
is actually outputting what it should be
it might be something we have to like
lower the resolution or refresh your
stream to fix but less appeared though
thank you I have not been doing anything
to it for months I'm a I'm a disgusting
person 10 but in a good way
how's this it's not taking place on the
original map no so apparently all of the
expansions for this game all have their
own dedicated areas talking over this
lady right now so they're a bucket list
ooh is it fun how much is it it's $20
USD included in one of the multiple
passes oh the Cobra coil that's a Hot
Wheels car if I ever saw it has a Hot
Wheels logo on it okay how big is the
map it seems pretty big it's not
anything like the original map though
but it's sizeable see some drifting be
ready to break out your best
Tokyo Drift impression here I don't know
if this is going to be a good part of
track for it you know they've got to
have some good stuff with your best tip
on drifting I hold on tight don't let go
wolf right another dinosaur mouth said
to test that make sure that it's
actually there confirmed the dinosaur is
physically a thing I wish that I could
give you guys like a number like how big
the actual map is but I can give just a
rough idea this is that spiral this is
where you do that drift this this is
where you do that drift although I don't
know if I'd you're trying to get a speed
how much $20 u.s. $20 and I gotta I have
uh try it again eight miles per hour to
stir you got it this time we got it I'm
not gonna try to tell you to drift
because that's not how you keep your
speed up though it looks really cool uh
is it in steam release date not on Steam
it's on the Microsoft Store but it is
out today so there's that have you even
played for us before yes Daniel I
guarantee that we both have probably
played more more Forza than you think we
have can you enter the dinosaur map
there is a part of the map called
Jurassic who's gonna call it Jurassic
Junction I don't remember the actual
other word for it but there's a part
makes me think there's a lot of cool
dinosaur things
how many Hot Wheels cars are there we
can check that out in a bit I think
there's like maybe like twelve or
fifteen yeah
so if I can get that's when payment
speed I agree aquiline that Ford is
definitely a sexy machine a little bit
more optimistic this time how much is it
in Euros I wish I could tell you but I'm
not good at math I couldn't math my way
out of a paper bag and I don't know
conversion rates on Xbox one we are on
Xbox one rip I don't know if we're going
to be taking online challenges yet today
but you're welcome to jump in and start
racing around success we get a success
kill adapt drift for us crashes in the
barrier that's how it goes man what is
what is DK stand for not Donkey Kong
why isn't it playable it should be
I might have to like update or something
for you but English Pounds that shows
you how not up on things I am new radio
stations in the DLC I don't believe so
we're still kind of listen to the same
jams more geez which means hold on to
your hair boss more geez who cares about
that sky track ya see the first-person
view all first-person you just got to be
great in this you take that request can
we change the rims of the cars with the
regular ones you can I don't know if
there's like a licensing thing with Hot
Wheels where we might not be able to but
we can drive up there we go to the Auto
Show we hit fast travel and we can check
out the cars and see like what they do
for customization while you're asking
questions I don't play Forza because you
might be curious and you want to know
more and I like talking to you and I
want to help you out as best I can
let's mail for download on PC but you
can't play it till tomorrow oh maybe
there's a thing with the PC version not
being ready yet is a very big
possibility of the expansion patch will
grab all the Hot Wheels goodness for
free well I mean free except for the
fact that you paid for the expansion
pass but it's included it's not fails go
to the garage I think right and then not
there it should be in the Auto Show so
get a place to buy buy the vehicles
maybe we're being blocked up because it
is Hot Wheels specific cars it's
possibly
let's make our way all you might have
done like a thing where yeah you might
have to like actually race to get to the
point to actually use the new ones so
we're right at the beginning of the DLC
I actually somehow tricked my xbox into
downloading it last night but I couldn't
do it which is very important so I
bought the blizzard mountain expansion
I'd say get this one if you want one
like if you're just gonna buy one over
the other this just look at this look at
that
stormy
my Hot Wheels new DLC you can buy it
separately which is what I was just
talking about the time is the update in
the UK I wish I could tell you Billy but
I I don't know I want to help you
believe me but I don't know the other
time release dates it'd be nice if we
just got worldwide releases you know oh
you have to go in you to see all the new
cars okay
so we'll hit that up again after we do
this race we'll get it right this time
we'll do it on can you roam around the
map yeah it's still open world you can
still kind of drive around at you or at
your own leisure do your own thing
alright the Ocean Spray circuit oh these
are regular cars you can take the
Warthog on the Hot Wheels track
apparently Tet auto upgrade
yeah I got enough credits can you give
me your account no not today
I legendary I'm sure that you've got
some real real cool things you want to
do with my account but no it's mine
please
BAM alright getting ready to go into a
race here it's going to be a good time
so I guess you can just bring any cars
in because those are definitely not Hot
Wheels cars you can roam around
any news on the Scorpion I assume you
mean the Scorpio and I don't know if
there's been anything big since they
showed off the debug kit but you can
find all the news you want about it on
gamespot.com where we have a ton of news
updates and cool features about the
actual the power of the scorpio and what
it's bringing hairpin but i feel like we
probably won't be seeing a lot more
stuff until III which is right around
the corner guys holy cow
III is coming up fast how are you
enjoying the game so far you having a
good time Miguel no absolutely there you
go heard from the man himself he's
having a great time let's just look at
this
Oh chick Hot Wheels cars on the original
map I'm wondering if it goes both ways
probably possibly I don't know if we're
gonna try it but just look at how crazy
this is
I'm not a big fan of the bumper cam I'm
really into the in cockpit view though
like the like you're actually in there
and you're doing that kind of thing
especially pronouncing my name properly
bro I try and definitely if any of you
skill chain come on oh man I gotta keep
it going if I say any of you guys his
name's wrong like let me know I want to
make sure that I do that right some kind
of new tires ah score I haven't heard
anything but I definitely be interested
in finding that out does this game have
all the cars in the wheels line not all
of them there are a lot of cars hot
wheels have been around for a long time
yes
so I cash in my points what do I think
of the current state of memes I think
that they could be better on completed
there are some some good break out memes
in this year 2017 but I feel like we
could really try a bit harder but it is
kind of still early you know it's ok I
mean I'm proud of the fact that I am in
the organization where that old that has
Giant Bomb and the fact that drew became
a meme owed rusev a big timing you know
he left because you got all that me
money no no me money at all it's not a
real thing man where's the update it
should happen uh if you're on console
I'll set it earlier I'll recommend maybe
hard resetting your console and then
bring it back up maybe it'll recognize
that it needs to be updated yeah should
be good Mario karts better you know I
like Mario Kart a lot being the GameSpot
oh no cart champion
that's not how cars work it's the
opposite of how cars work up I respect
both games though I like myself some
Forza horizon 3 a lot but I also enjoy
Mario Kart a lot uh you know what seen
yet or shout you out shout out to you
looking good today
I hope you have a good rest here your
time at work or school or hanging out
wherever you are and same thing for you
guys everyone else I hope you all have a
good day today I want to thank you for
hanging out with us while we check out
this new DLC you know cars aren't meant
to fly either there's a lot of rules of
cars being broken here in this on xbox
can this be for 360 I believe they've
left the 360 behind the 360 is no longer
thing people are really into due to this
expansion pack for free legendary it is
not free it is included in the expansion
pass though or bought separately for 20
dollars USD Mikey putting that as a
disclaimer because I don't know how much
it is anywhere else are there blue
shells no but this game could benefit
from them do you think this has the same
physics model using the vanilla game I
believe it's the same physics but
they're just doing crazy things with the
track feels like it yeah cuz it's I
haven't got a chance to drive it yet but
it looks like it's driving very
similarly
do you close the fridge with your hips
whenever I can and I want to feel like
I'm the coolest guy in the room it's
very fun I recommend it I can't remember
last time I did that but I'm not above
doing it but yeah I mean it's sometimes
you just gotta like you have two things
in your hands and you don't want to like
you know like you got like a cool glass
of orange juice in the morning and you
don't want to like risk having it spill
a little bit use your hip and just kind
of time you hit it and it goes another
second place uh well at least I got one
of the challenges that's all good yeah
so apparently if we go to view all in
the garage it will show us where where
the cars are where the cars live is the
expansion worth buying uh if you like
Forza horizon and driving games and if
you like Hot Wheels I'd say yes if
you're curious about Forza horizon I
mean does this look like something
that's fun to you Roulettes and cool
orange roads endless orange roads is
this ModNation racers negative this is
not ModNation racers but we were long
overdue for a new one I actually kind of
enjoyed it I really should the diversity
of united front games considering they
also made sleep sleeping dogs which I
also loved a lot dragon you know what my
shoutout you to dragon I hope you're
having a good day thank you for hanging
out uh glad to have you here on this
wonderful Tuesday it's Tuesday I thought
we were much further on in the week when
I realized where we were why is he
racing with the line option on what are
you noob XD JK JK I'm glad that you Jake
hate on that because you know sometimes
it's good to have that guiding line
because in a world like this where we
need as much guidance as as we need God
you know it's good to have something
that we can rely on especially in a race
mode where
you can't really see where things are
these tracks are not natural if you
could not tell they could go anywhere
any given moment three gigs there you go
are the cars available by themselves I
believe you can only get them through
the pack love your channel I love you
dragon keep doing you I have a beard
like me uh Alan I'll tell you what you
can do if you want a beard like mine you
you pray that you've got the genetics
for a beard and then you just be really
lazy and you don't do anything with it
it's it's a thing it's a real real thing
Peyton I'm gonna shut you out two and an
ev3 Abdal you guys and Alyssa hello it's
good to see you I'm glad that you're
here even though you're right outside
the room and everyone else who's
watching in the office do you play call
of duty if yes then give me some tips ah
I used to play call of duty a lot not so
much anymore but I pick the submachine
gun in some of the games because they're
really good they shoot fast and people
die fast
that's my Call of Duty tip for the day
Mini Cooper woohoo
my wife just bought a Mini Cooper I I
respect since was it the Italian job or
the all drove Mini Coopers through the
subway system
I respect Mini Coopers a lot ever since
that how does it feel to be a national
treasure uh pretty good I love that
movie highly recommend Nic Cage is great
actor so there you are
hey are you streaming Terry we are
streaming right here live for you all
this music right now I'm just gonna I'm
gonna turn this up a little bit because
it's this is the thing I'm supposed to
do a big job or something
miguel 'this is everything you've been
working up towards is it this whole
thing everything this entire stream
hinges on this one moment you in a mini
cooper driving on this orange road is
get ready to go fast here it is
get ready buckle up here comes any
moment now coming around this edge just
gonna hear it as you ready ah that's not
as big as I thought it would be still
exciting nonetheless number one success
you got to the destination yay that
that's very much like a bring up Metal
Gear Solid 2 again the the line that
ridin says after he's got an Emma
through the through the underwater area
Colonel its ridin I'm here with them oh
we've managed to avoid drowning like you
made it to the place man gratz ah man
have an international recording team if
yes how do we join it I have no clue in
that international recording team are we
like a band I do you want to start a
band oh no I'm getting my quotes taken
out of context now and I don't know what
to think I'm not going to read my quote
because it's a bit incriminating stop at
the top of the loop does the best keep
up the good work
Thank You wolf I'm glad that we could
entertain all of you on this wonderful
Tuesday morning like I said I didn't
realize it was that early in the week oh
yeah that's right there's a there's one
one barn-find here I don't think we've
actually picked it up yet so we don't
really know where it is unless it's just
something we look good by two treasure
map whoo
options did you tune that mini-cooper
not it was for a a bucket-list thing so
we didn't get a chance to crap off right
at the camera my goodness
was done pooping 20 minutes ago which
guys haven't glued to the seat thank you
you know Miguel anything I can do other
Miguel in the chat its credit that again
well there's an XP board somewhere here
I guess I've to go onto the beach we
have a request to not crash on this song
and I think we've already already done
they like the song I was a Kiki Lana I
think said that they like that I mean
I'm I'm down with most jams Miguel it's
not I'm trying to get the XP board okay
well in never mind then I didn't see
there's more not in times there's over
25 it's not too bad that's a quote of
someone else's quote we can't quote me
on a quote that I said of someone else's
because that's like stealing in some way
there's like a copyright rule for
something like that I think oh yeah I
can we can we go back and try to show
the cars okay quick so I am really
curious myself you guys say goodbye to
me so I go to sleep now no dragon you
have to stay here forever until the
stream is over I mean which is not
really forever but you're here
getting expansion tomorrow I can't wait
it sounds good Mario I'm excited for you
get the expansion I'm excited to
actually sit down and play the expansion
myself yeah stop at the top of loop uh
we can we can try stopping at the top of
the loop um I think I know it'll happen
but it'll be fun to do all right new car
to collect has been headed to your
garage what would you rate this DLC 1
out of 10 I would do that but I'm not a
reviewer for the site unfortunately all
right are we doing a review for this sir
I believe not okay well I mean I can
give you as a thumbs up and say is good
time well there is a Hot Wheels tab ooh
here we go let's let's take it back in
let's let's go through all these cars
no it's just that oh just just that
that's all we have right now is the
Boneshaker
yeah we show the first race it's got a
skull on it and flames which means it
goes faster than most other cars these
are car facts brought to you by GameSpot
comm I'm glad that you're here for me to
share is it better than Blizzard
Mountain I'm willing to make the call
yeah probably I'm gonna say it is so
where's that see all option again uh uh
maybe in the in the thing I think
they're blocking us out from it it might
be I don't see you see all you guys were
the see all button help me I don't know
what's happening
check out how much does each sticker add
mph wise I'm glad you asked a couple a
couple mph s V all under Auto Show okay
be game on point Thank You Cameron I did
it up real nice just for you guys today
for this stream demand a drift King hot
wheel same you mean like a like what if
we're able to get like a Hot Wheels
version of Bow Wow's car from Tokyo
Drift the like the Hulk minivan I drift
it I drift that real good okay people
are saying go to the Auto Show uh here
we go here we go and that's there the
Hot Wheels there they are okay found
them Mustang the twin mill it's got two
engines so it goes twice fast
mathematically for four free cars I'm
sure there's more but let's I already
have these oh there we go uh we might
actually have someone giving us the
proper numbers ten new cars it I don't
that sounds right I'm into it tried too
hard story of my life right angle every
day I try too damn hard of a new
Landmaster just tracks Tommy I'm glad
you asked it is a completely new area
kind of like how Blizzard Mountain did
theirs it's a land filled with dinosaurs
and crazy orange tracks go to all cars
and scroll through cars till you see a
symbol next to the DLC cars
yes warthog I love halo as well halo is
a good game is Vin Diesel in this uh
legend says if you find a way to drive
into the dinosaur he's in there living
inside driving it actually it's a it's a
robot dinosaur people already have paint
jobs out for these things
Audrey toes Mountain Dew
the barn-find is also hotwheels variant
that's good I'm into that one this is
dope will it be on PC you bet it is
it'll be on PC hopefully today I saw
some people saying it might be like a
little bit later on but I don't think
that's the case but yeah exactly him
driving that robot dinosaure in his one
last drive is exactly how it works what
is this - two cars like fused together
is that the gimmick no it's just two
cars two engines nevermind I didn't see
the engines I forgot what we were doing
thanks Johnny that the Deadpool car is
great for SEO I hear people love their
Deadpool come on guys drive so we got
people want to see the cars you got
people who want to drive we can't make
everyone happy but we're gonna try our
best we'll get there we'll get it's okay
just keep your pants on just pull them
up hold on tight what's up right angle
No looking good
some Mad Max DLC for you I think I
actually had a Mad Max car in the
original game which is canonically
correct
cuz it's in Australia how much is this
oh wait I could have to go into the
store welcome to the Microsoft Store
everybody never mind
here we are - want to keep your pants on
or guys it's okay little secret about
pants they're just a suggestion you
don't have to keep them on
do you drive and show cars please Tommy
here's a car
here's that car driving
gotcha
do some tricks do a trick Miguel got
apparently do a trick do a do a reverse
180
stalefish method grab do it and do a
flip dude do it do a cool flip trick
Thank You Shawn customization wait we're
trying trying to turn to what we can for
you guys I'm glad that you appreciate it
hurry up this is driving game all you do
is hurry up it's all about going fast
I love the Microsoft Store this my
favorite game go back dry angle you're
the best kind of person and for all of
you guys who are enjoying your time here
in the stream
give us a follower subscribe depending
on where you are so you don't miss any
of our cool shows or videos that we do
got tons great original content you can
catch stuff like Mike's got his really
cool
reboot series that he's got going on you
guys can actually like take part in that
influence it's a really cool like
opinion driven show we call do you have
anything cool here you're working on
that all the travel-time yeah the key
word is not you always got to put that
on that's the cavea yeah I'm helping out
the team a little bit on some prey
playthroughs there you go we'll have
some some cool prey stuff coming up then
if you're diggin that this is forza
horizon 3 is this out yet it's out today
conner today
got a grip oh yeah try the first-person
view in this car cuz I guarantee it's
gonna be some real garbage but in the
best way
sorry about my crappy rooms and guys
ocean ugh
oh uh MLD I believe or ml6 like your
name is very small I'm hungry Audrey but
they said according to some PC users if
you open the hot wheels game you might
lose your savegame so I guess be careful
out there PC users and don't get your
game deleted please I beg you I'll
proceed with caution
but please do proceed 160 miles all
right
Joey this is a thing that I got a lot uh
so I've worked for other various video
game sites where I've had to use my
voice or my physical personage and I get
told a lot that a either sound like
badger from breaking bad or Jimmy to
Santa from Grand Theft Auto which didn't
help when I was doing Grand Theft Auto
mods uh I've been told that I look like
a gamma del Toro I'll take that I at one
point people called me like the Seth
Rogen of the site that I was working for
I don't know I don't see it Sony real
garbage but in a good way ste I'm
getting all these good quotes ah
goodness turned off traction control but
you need traction control to keep your
life in line it's very important well it
might be a thing that might mess with
the drifting though
yo where do you find this on the map I
can't find it just bought it um
so apparently people are also having
issues have like actually haven't show
up in the game but we pretty much we
started it up and it rolled like an
intro right mm-hmm so if if it picks up
you'll know right away but other than
that to actually get to the DLC the
first festival you get in the campaign
it's like right down the street from
that
can you drive normal car so you can
bring the normal cars in here you see
what we're racing against some right now
oh yeah I believe you can take them in
here don't turn off traction control
seat there you go good to go
this is nack - no it's not nekked -
though I did play neck - last week oh
there you go yeah you have some stuff
coming up for that or just a couple
thoughts about it um one interesting
takeaway from that appointment that
hands-on appointment was that
remember those Capcom games like in the
mid-2000s where if you were doing poorly
they would ask for the nut you were
interested in playing ez mode
oh no so every time I died so to speak
mark Cerny would jump on on co-op Oh
and just help me get through certain
sections really thoughtfully uh it was
an honor I played Mac to with the man
the myth the legend yeah only when I
sucked look that's the secret though you
got to be bad to get it to happen
not bad she's having a rough time so
it's understandable though shifting to
early I think you're playing automatic
right yeah for the purposes of the
screen yeah
so the car is doing it by itself the
calls coming from inside the car does
anything like Blizzard Mountain you'll
have to downloads one for the content
and one for actually having a DLC so I
can unlock thing okay that makes sense
you can access the game if you don't
yeah it's available to you at any point
in time which is really nice yeah you
want to try the the in the cockpit you
really quick Anna thing I know I don't
oh just there's a spinal column running
up the middle the car getting real
physical with that guy driving that I
don't know what that is off the top of
my head she got real physical with him
isn't an act 2 for kids aren't video
games for kids hot wheels for kids hot
wheels are for kids Noma let you in on a
secret we all love a thing that is meant
for kids but we fell in love with it as
kids and it's following us into
adulthood so in fact anything that's
really for kids kind of for us anyway
boom lodgings
is manual it's better but I'm really
lazy Freddie ah though I do appreciate
wanting to have more control over your
car and do that manual shifting and
reenact all your favorite fast and
furious moments I like to keep it all
not like that
finally did it you got each get first ah
killing it dude
all you have to do is get the bone
shaker shake those bones make it happen
you know I would say that I feel I don't
feel bad necessarily for PlayStation
Gran Turismo is a fantastic series and I
hope that they might like cuz they did
like go-karts in like the fifth one or
something like I hope you do more fun
stuff but I did um we just got access to
the Gran Turismo sport beta so we're
hoping to show some of that up to you
later this week we'll figure it out
favorite fast and furious moments is a
contradictory statement I beg your
pardon
exactly men are just bigger kids just
the fun thing about the jobs we do is we
basically just took a thing we loved as
kids and somehow we're just able to
still be like dumb grown-up kids like
getting paid for a thing we like it's
real weird I
[Music]
yeah I recently did derive my wife's
mini-cooper treated it a little bit like
a sports car really any loopy loops you
can drive on you bet
we drove they do want a warthog on a
road like this I can take the work hard
we're all gonna be pretty cool I'm gonna
do it let's take a look on hello Mario I
see you welcome
maybe's dope I I'm curious I want to try
it out I've always kind of been a that's
the ocean it's not the ocean that's pond
that's a puddle you found a puddle what
happens when you stop on a soup or just
go slowly a slope suit loops a loop I I
assume you fall physics take over how
much of the map of you explored so far
we I think we've been to a couple of the
areas and if at the ballpark it may be a
quarter of the map
maybe corner yeah I collect hot wheels I
used to collect hot wheels
love car bullet time
I'd like some glow-in-the-dark cars
Mario Kart texturepack you can actually
find things like that for the vinyls and
put some cool Mario Kart things on your
cars anyway I did that with a beach
buggy it's fantastic
cuz they're awesome keep up the good
work
thank you thanks guys I appreciate it
but if I can do anything to like help
anyone have a good time I'm down you
suck yeah that's okay Jake you can have
your opinion but I want to let you know
that it hurts a little bit but but thank
you what can we do we got we got people
asking us to stop at the top of the loop
they want to know sounds like it'll
really mean a lot to them started my
gaming still nothing I have no idea
I maybe restart and restart the eye I'm
just shooting off the top of my head at
this point I have no idea how to fix it
brother is going to be so happy he loves
Hot Wheels and has a lot of them this is
good right up his alley then steam
better with a keyboard or a controller
I'm going to say controller I like like
you playing this game with a controller
it's different between orange and blue
tracks I'm not a Hot Wheels master but I
think the blue tracks are the ones that
are like they have changes in elevation
I am the hot wheels engineers how they
do all this they asked how horizon
where's the Nos
so they have boosts but they work when
you drive over certain parts of the
track there's not like a button for it
but I mean it's there how much is this
DLC cost it's $20 USD all regime you're
very nice person thank you thank you
okay guys I'm gonna I don't think this
is the loop you guys were asking for
this is uh it looks like it's a thing
it's it loopy enough for you guys cause
I'll just stuff it hit the brake and
fall my god you're upside down hit that
brake you know how someone wouldn't let
you fall
oh yeah oh yeah maybe grab Dom doesn't
take over huh you go guys I'm gonna be
last place that's fine Wow goodness that
was pretty much a loop this is pretty
loopy
yeah you just jump through those
buildings that's too much for me oh
there we go blue tracks or connector
tracks us they can also be changed out
okay that's what that's the other thing
I like having a live chat here for is
there are people who obviously know
better than me we can get the proper
answers
dead as a hot wheel truck collection
that's why I think this is kind of a
cool thing too because it kind of there
are a lot of people who collects Hot
Wheels and there are a lot of people who
like Forza and it brings them all
together it's great marks using a Hot
Wheels car oh wow
it splits sometimes you got to not use
the Hot Wheels car you know sometimes
you got to you got to pick whatever car
fits for the race you're doing people
really need to read the the live
comments to answer their questions yeah
true
I'll have to play the DLC thanks for
hanging out emails it was good I hope I
said that right it was good hanging out
with you I hope you have a fun time with
the DLC and uh have a good day do a
barrel roll I mean when we get the
chance that one of those slanted Rams
one of those cool things some time to
get the DLC to work it's not on the map
I also heard someone else in the chat
earlier was saying that ah you have to
get a second update that activates the
DLC sort of like a license so there
might be like a Forza horizon update
that you have to download maybe you can
find that on the game page um but yeah I
that's my next my next bit of advice for
you try to look for that I don't know
how true it is but I trust a lot of you
in the chat how much is the expansion
$20 to USD we should just get like it
like a sign to hang up in the background
it means we could just swap stuff out
try stopping before the jump I wonder
what happens when you go down we try I
mean seems like you still make it yeah
you were you were hitting the brakes
right
no oh nevermind I won't get first place
oh yeah you I'll show you I'll Jake
requests on the first lap of every race
okay because it seems like I actually
have a fighting chance to get back let's
just say you did a pretty good job
catching up and getting everything all
together
what's that trademark drive ATAR
technology boom well what's the next
game overhead that we're going to play I
don't think there are any other streams
planned for to that I think we actually
do have one more forget what game it was
but we have another one for two o'clock
we might have another stream coming up
for you at two o'clock out the hot
stream ready to just come in and hang
out
if anyone outside knows what that is let
me know destiny there's a destiny stream
today I'm hearing wonderful pack up get
ready later on today we'll be doing a
destiny stream
[Music]
I apologize for my driving and we don't
got first place you got first place you
have nothing to apologize for
I know they can't see that's what the we
intentionally covered up the place that
you're in just to draw up the tension we
need to get a couple more points a
couple more medals to unlock for the
other reasons
oh it's iron banner they have a special
mayhem mode going on up today so that'll
be fun some cool PvP okay I'm just gonna
go for however many quotes I can get oh
you get you got all three of the day
killing it need to try mafia 3 I
actually really want to I haven't gotten
around to it eight soundtrack great
soundtrack is what I hear just now yeah
so it's going to double down if you guys
want to see some cool Destiny's PvP
action later on odd keep it keep it here
you know
it'll be a good time what's your
favorite Hot Wheels car it's a good
question I had this really cool green
one when I was a kid it wasn't like any
of the cool a trademark ones but I liked
it a lot because it had like a like a
suspension kind of thing in it was
really fun to play with but no ojou
Miguel what's what's your favorite hot
with a scarf gosh I knew I had hot
wheels as a kid hmm I'm sorry I can't
the ones I had because I mean I was more
to hot wheels before I was into like
cars in general make sense so I didn't
have the opportunity to play favorites
are you two going to play this
off-camera after this ah yes yes not a
doubt I'm on a guess I'm going to play
this so much 15:15 drifter okay really
appreciate this livestream as
interactive as you guys are big thumbs
up for watching I'm glad that you had a
good time and I'm glad that you're
looking forward to future streams
I also saw someone speaking of future
streams asking if we're going to be
streaming injustice too and I'm just
going to go out and say yeah yes we're
definitely going to be uh someone might
need to go check on Jake I think he
might have fallen onto his keyboard port
a shout-out you shout out to you MC
ultra thanks for hanging out I hope you
have a good day we show the whole map I
would show the map again it's been a bit
so cool bring it up Oh an underwater
track would be kind of interesting I'm
in yeah Jake you pick your head off for
the keyboard dude I'm worried about you
hope you're okay
those frame drops potato console or PC
neither it's more than likely an actual
stream this is also a jam are we gonna
like hold on there's gonna be claps
coming up that's how you know when the
fun happens in the song is when the hand
claps happen last there it is buzz -
link oh my gosh
I didn't fall off okay let's see can you
do a giveaway we do giveaways almost
every single lobby we do which all
happen on Wednesdays and you should
watch our guys out real this here
it's fine you're still in a good
position to move up in the race
I love you too brick media do modular
trucks did you imagine an entire
expansion focused on just monster trucks
because that sounds fantastic to me and
I'd be really into it definitely gonna
watch it injustice to stream we've got
some people who are very into injustice
and it'll it'll be a good time
I guarantee you this that injustice to
stream will be fantastic come May 16th I
want to get that drift target can you
push other cars from the track we did
fall off earlier so I assume you can but
Miguel is a polite driver and he's not
going to do a murder on any of these
people you're we're doing a murder
you're doing the exact opposite of what
I said you weren't gonna do I didn't
mean to
I'm just saying love your challenge
progress your vids love love you
Jasin I think that's I got the door
challenge on my system and let's see
what is it first a motorcycle expansion
would be fantastic to write I have been
playing um I'm still been playing
driveclub quite a bit really yeah there
was a sale on like season pass content
gotcha yeah it's it's a pretty good game
it's it's not entirely for me but I can
see what's good about it I do they have
a track editor yet I don't believe so
the but there's a challenge editor yeah
you can you can take what existing the
game and make your own kind of challenge
out of like going through and doing your
own path but it's still within the
existing game world yeah
[Music]
ah
Stadium super trucks are ridiculous saw
them on the long beach circuit last
weekend as sounds like a really good
time and I'm a bit envious to be honest
so that's actually another thing a key
LAN that I actually am curious about as
if the ad equation I don't remember this
song being in this DLC at all or in the
game at all originally okay so I don't
know if they did that I also only
listened to like the hip-hop station oh
yeah
start tracks motorcycles monster trucks
all that good stuff
where's the fast and furious DLC it was
in the last game they already did that
but it'd be good to bring it back anyway
that's not what I wanted bring the
screen back wonderful did it oh here we
go
woof no like yeah jeez you're killing me
here
uh-uh everything's fine now like ours to
access the DLC I'll model it dude I'm
proud of you got this last boost it's
almost like everyone else wasn't
eligible for that last boost I just like
passed by like five cars yeah skewing it
yeah I like to go fast - just like Sonic
the Hedgehog may also enjoy going fast
song was in the game before all right
I'll take your word for it
I trust you I trust you
does your car explode if upside down not
just resets nothing too exciting they're
still licensed cars I don't think they
want to blown up at all but those metals
alright let's see what can we unlock
shout out to you
fack the moles I got you I hope you're
having a good day we go yes we went over
the barn fire not yet I don't know if it
gets marked or if you just have to find
it but we've heard it is also a Hot
Wheels car if you could believe that oh
I believe it ha there's one thing that I
can say I definitely agree with it's
that this the barn find is a Hot Wheels
car all right you know we haven't gone
to the Jurassic jungle let's make our
way there there's also a pretty good
loop down there how fast do you like to
go pretty fast but not too fast because
I'm also concerned for my safety but
pretty fast believe that you guys
remember the Hot Wheels acceleracers
movies I do not unfortunately are they
good should I check them out this this
is your chance to suggest a thing to me
is this something that I want to check
out as a person who's a fan of Forza and
the hotness DLC you drive Hot Wheels
cars in Blizzard Mountain maybe we
haven't done it like that what you guys
have seen is all we play to us so we're
we're still figuring out things as we're
going yeah what didn't book I went into
line yeah Jonas shoutout to you because
you you ask so nicely and you had a
proper punctuation in there I hope
you're having a good day as well say a
speed you're not the boss of me I don't
need to say a speed keep it ambiguous
can't tell where I'm going I can't tell
what I'm doing this looks similar to how
a bush Mountain is with the coins
progress that is exactly they took the
same same system fans aren't a thing out
here it's all off of
is this Forza Motorsport 7 negative
ghostrider this is Forza Motorsport 4
Forza horizon 3 hot wheels DLC ok I got
a question for the stream does anyone
know whether or not you could
accidentally come across barn-find
before you get like a little clue
notification in Forza horizon 3 because
I always waited for the little
notification a little sort of general
area
circle that will pop in and I know those
are time can you like accidentally like
come across the barn I feel you want to
get the clue I feel like it's possible I
subscribed how are you guys thank you
John for subscribing I'm doing fantastic
how are you how are you dinosaur tail
woo don't drive up there that looks real
dangerous and I would not suggest it
hello
that that's a very databasing line is
telling me to go there Miguel that's doc
that's a dinosaur bottom nope
woke up in a new Bugatti as classic song
fantastic ok so you can't is what the
majority of people are saying cut so you
have to have notification for it I will
just wait hopefully we'll get a
notification soon yeah thank you guys
right yeah for help I'm like we kept
getting those notifications like every
like 90 minutes of playtime right ok the
afternoon ok
yeah yeah see just go through playing
Hot Wheels has a question I have to
waking over I I really appreciate like
everyone's like totally down to help out
like this this is a good this is a good
stream you guys are the best Chet don't
tell any other streams but you guys are
the best ones on the DL ahh
Shh low stream stoked play same actually
I was a little disheartened when I
learned that Miguel said he wanted to do
the playing oh why are you in a what did
you pick that yeah oh nice if if only
the Halo theme were playing which is
definitely a thing the Glen fatigues
know oh oh do they change your outfit
cuz I know they did for Blizzard mouths
rawr Oh apparently people are saying
with the DLCs you can accidentally find
them right you want tell IGN I said that
a lot of friends over there they're nice
people you guys rock no you rock Jay Jay
you're not starving I had coffee so I'm
doing pretty alright I am looking
forward to lunch Stern a new subscriber
keep with the group work Thank You Isaac
I appreciate it and I look forward to
seeing you in future streams never
played this game how is the handling
asked MC call so Forza I mentioned
earlier it does a good job of kind of
straddling simulation in arcade so it's
kind of in between but you can also
tweak a lot of the settings to kind of
tailor it more towards one direction or
the other which is kind of nice because
like some days you just want to like I
want to go in and I want to have a fun
race where I'm going up a wall sideways
or something or other days I want to
have like pretty good simulation where
I've actually got to like break into my
turns and stuff so it's kind of cool
stuff werehog will be too slow for the
loop ha we just did the loop in the
Warthog it was fast enough because of
the boosts my stream head head home to
get the expansion catch you guys later
keep it up
you got it dude have fun playing the
expansion up go fast win the races I
don't really know how to do words of
encouragement very well so I just say
things and hopefully they they come
across pretty well subscribe to the best
channel Robert thank you I love this
every classroom loved guys are great you
guys are all too good I love this this
this is fantastic you you guys are
making my day handling is awesome Isaac
yeah that's the other thing we're also
talking about handling on tracks me not
plastic like how how realistic can this
be this car is too slow definitely but
it makes up for the slowness with cool
points because it's cool it's from halo
yeah you do make a good point you know
what that change occurs oh my goodness
a nod president had moved from Miguel
it's really that unprecedented it's
unprecedented I can't believe what's
happened here today in this this life's
good thing we're not playing like
side-scrolling shooters because I'm in
that camp yeah that you know like you
play like Gradius once you like lose all
your power-ups like - why what's the
point
ya just gotta go all the way back wait
oh shoot I don't want that car girl this
is the same car I don't want to be that
guy DLC makes me miss my childhood what
you can relive it here Jacob in Forza
horizon 3 not just trying to sell things
I promise I'm just really passionate
about this game and I like it a lot
can you knock cars off the edge I think
so we fell off the let the edge earlier
and it was really intense yeah I'm
getting this Ferrari this is halo my
favorite game oh man here we are yeah
this is the new DLC for halo where you
could drive Ferraris around it's real
good
the expansion this weekend I'm so
excited by the way great stream you guys
are awesome thank you Joe I appreciate
you and I'm excited for you to get your
hands on this cool little wasting
expansion yes it was quite overcast in
the other half an hour ago yeah there
there's weather thunderstorms actually I
think it's a for the horizon to it like
it's whole gimmick for one of its DLCs
was it was like a storm island or
something yeah they're all about weather
in here it actually affects car handling
too which was pretty good not too much
but feels like a little bit of a magnum
p.i thing going on here it's kind of
nice well one my favorite um video games
and arcade racers is outrun whoo nice
dude you play the the cuff it's like a
reap it I guess the remake that they put
out on like the 360 like a couple years
ago yeah well outrun to came out on the
original
spots huh and yeah it's a that's a
favorite as well I like that one a lot I
like oh yeah they actually put like the
whole of the original outrun in Yakuza
zero which is fantastic
it's a good game how long did it take to
download this it's two and a half gigs
so not long depending on your internet
connection it's not too big not too
crazy this car slippery yeah are you
guys doing a desti stream later we are
well it's not us but we will be doing a
destiny stream later on this very
channel wherever you're watching twitch
YouTube anywhere you'll be here first
dream I'm watching with you guys will
welcome I'm glad that you're here uh AB
Nev I think I said it right if I didn't
I'm so sorry but welcome in either case
this is Call of Duty my favorite game
same man keep you my favorite part of
Call of Duty is when you do the loop on
the track we go Mario Kart looks way
different is this DLC you bet it is all
DLC but not from Mario Kart this cars
gonna suck long term and it changed cars
after this track number but I will stick
with it until the other ice
Poots wants to know great name by the
way what platform are we playing this on
this is on the Xbox one home
entertainment console it's also on the
PC though but how is the community
regarding collisions in Forza so this is
actually a legitimate question because
there are a lot of people like to ram
online uh I'd say at the beginning there
probably was a bigger problem with it
but now it seems like the people who are
still playing are the people who care
about the game and they don't really do
that it's pretty good what up goob it's
good to see you hey goob looking good
this up is the best Call of Duty yet
challenge for you take a sip of your
coffee I drank it all spoilers it's gone
now there's no more coffee left good job
thank you
I pride myself on my ability to finish
coffee what's the challenge more people
who who care about it I'd say that just
because they it's been out for like not
I don't want to say a year but it's been
out for a while now yeah I came out of
the fall yeah so it's it's been around
for a bit I feel like a lot of like the
initial people who aren't very
interested it may have like tapered off
a bit the DLC might bring a lot of an
ultimate drift
dang dude ultimate clean racing ultimate
clean racing this is my first video with
you guys and I really enjoy it I'm glad
you're having a good time Nathan I'm
happy that we could make your your first
video enjoyable and I hope I like waving
at the losers on the other parts of the
track got our way behind me talking mad
poop Miguel but I don't understand I'm
at school all jinxed myself I'm not
gonna get first King what are you doing
watching us at school you should be
getting your learn on thank you for
hanging out what's your favorite subject
Hey what's your favorite thing in school
to study I like parts were I'm not in
school with least school
I like the part with the least school
still heading to wall come on come on
come on quit driving cars issue so this
is a Halo game why are you not haloing
you know it's that happens later on in
the game they did this weird thing with
the new halo where you have to drive for
75% of it and eventually chief is like
oh he's trying to finish the fight he
gets up and he he gets out and that's
when the actual halo shooting happens
yeah
crazy crazy direction it's good time
though yes I actually know Aki LAN I
don't know if this is forza horizon
trees last DLC I'm willing about that we
still got car pax and I'm also under
benefits does well maybe they'll do
something else what's under the beanie
man come on tell us your secrets
ah a lot of hair because I need to get a
haircut and also an awful bald spot that
I am very embarrassed about which is why
I wear the hat but don't tell anyone
it's just a matter time for me and
balding thank you for curing my boredom
uh you're welcome I'm I'm happy I'm
happy that I can help you
Hanna it's a good time AB me Google+ do
it I don't got that how got that Google+
how are you playing I can't get on
so I heard some things about some extra
things you might have to download James
but I'm I'm not sure Miguel set this up
he took care of it I just showed up and
fors has happened yeah got that what
character are you most excited for an
injustice - that's a good question I'm
really excited for when the add a solid
snake to the game what
it's about adding Solid Snake to the
game I just I gotta keep my quota up
it's been 30 minutes now haven't talked
about metal gear so kind of put that up
right up there but truthfully uh I'm
kind of excited to try out a guy who
visits I don't want to say an old
character because that's really like
that's kind of boring captain Cole
because I hope he has puns also
scarecrow looks kind of interesting I
don't really like his outfit very much
but you get so many so many different
outfits in this one yeah is it worth the
price if you like Forza and you like Hot
Wheels definitely without a doubt if you
like Forza definitely without a doubt if
you don't own either and you're not big
up on Forza I'd say I mean does this
look cool it's a little dark right now
that'd be low you know it's fine
well Red Dead Redemption to online have
horst customizations we don't know
literally everything that is known about
Red Dead Redemption you guys know as
well but I hope that I can customize my
horse and Red Dead Redemption to is
online mode tell me your secrets and
lies I I really dislike Mediterranean
food oh my goodness
can't believe this oh ah also when I go
out to a restaurant I order a rice plate
shoot that's pretty good I mean it rice
it's nice I like it
I'm trying to think of like out like a
cool story I have or something
oh no I ran too long dollars why Mario
Cart DLC is so expensive I don't know
what that means the world is flat I
don't know about that man
but I've been in planes I've seen some
things there's some cool spam going on
in the chat know why you're doing that
well the last of us to be released
that's all I got for you there's just a
little bit of arm-flailing and nothing
else
why are people comparing this to Mario
Kart driving games just driving games
have the game looking into the DLC I'd
say go for it it's pretty good twenty
bucks but uh oh goodness
uh Miguel how long was this stream going
for 90 minutes it's 12 12 21 I'll leave
this rate for the wrap-up
dang guys it's almost the end of the
stream quick get all your questions in
about Forza Horizons new Hot Wheels DLC
or things you just want to ask us or
dating advice or whatever you have
because I don't know about dating advice
we are wrapping up the stream it's
coming to an end but don't worry because
uh this channel not us but this channel
will be back later on with a destiny
stream and I will have this video
archived yeah you'll be able to miss you
can watch us in at any time we won't be
able to talk to you but if we said your
name you could I play that section of
the clothes you want uh but if you are
watching in the future when we're not
live in the future
hello to you mysterious stranger who
stumbled upon this video this section is
for you calling you out saying hello one
of our driver tires went off went on
another part of the turn away there is
everybody he's back it's all good
I thought he was okay I know you've been
here since the beginning right angle and
I appreciate you doesn't look like
injustice to that's because it's not
neat dating advice
shoot shoot away I got you sounds like
badger from breaking bad yes I am badger
from breaking bad hello
how do you get out of the friendzone
just be you uh you know if it wasn't
meant to be it wasn't meant to be uh all
you can do is pick yourself up and and
move on you know where the mods there's
a lot of stuff going on today so they
might be busy question how much is too
much to spend on a first date good
question
where you going that's it that's a good
question uh you know sometimes you want
to go to like and in and out and just
get a really delicious hamburger and
that's pretty cheap yeah you know there
was this one girl I dated who I thought
I needed to spend like you know like at
least $50 for the both of us
little did I know that after like the
second date that oh all she wanted was
it enough it was happy to oblige you
know that that's the best kind like if
you weren't just like hang out and like
order pizza or something or like go to
an in-and-out like that's that's the jam
see how many extra hours of content does
this add a few I we haven't played
through it all the way like I said
earlier this is we both went in kind of
blind and we've just been kind of
experiencing this as it goes but well
the racing light disappeared because it
you went off to a different place what
but yeah then we've uh we've been
playing for like an hour and a half and
we've done like what through three four
races this is a lovely way to send up
because the Sun is rising churches is
playing it's all all metaphor
just hopped just hopped in what did you
do what did you miss I you know I some
cactus or dinosaurs not hurry Stephen
lying
answer me have you all tried recreating
how with I don't think we have we have
nots
unfortunately I'm sorry is the Acura
from pulp fiction might be I'm gonna
take it how much is the expansion $20
u.s. USD what's your favorite dish at
Red Lobster uh anything that involves
cheddar Bay biscuits so the big the big
secret about cheddar Bay biscuits is
that you can buy it don't add to this
home now don't tell me this Miguel don't
do this you can make it at home you can
make it better
you're not stopping a boxed version you
can make it at home you make it better
than the the ones you get at Red Lobster
you can add as much cheese as you want
you get bacon to it oh I have no reason
to go to the Red Lobster anymore
dang but what about the atmosphere no
big words from Miguel overrated no
that's not big worried that's a big word
man what car do you own I don't own any
cars anymore but I used to have a Impala
it's brown dumbbells pretty good talk
about ace you can't beat the TPD value
of a taco 12-pack though I am one of
those big fans of the jack and bucks
taco even though it's not technically a
taco I have a story about jackin the-box
tacos that I probably can't tell on
stream okay oh goodness
it involves you three though which makes
it topical but I'm not going to do it
okay
we're in the home stretch guys keep it
civil I agree listen to Joey
Joey's a smart boy be like Joey keep it
keep it real we've got four minutes just
four minutes that's it and then we'll be
gone and then destiny will happen and
all that stuff what year is like a 2001
is pretty old it was like my grandma's
car and I was like y'all take I'll take
it off it was it was gold
which was kind of nice it was definitely
old
Carlo but it went it went fast any copy
where I was going
look at that killing it man killing it I
want an open world Hot Wheels game right
now
that's great because you can get towards
the horizon three and do just that Joey
where's loud jackets though can't be
trusted that's also true but is a
fantastic jacket all right I'm just
gonna create roam a bit do you guys play
overwatch if so how much SR and what
rank are you i play competitive to place
and then I stop playing competitive and
then I just play like quick matching
arcade stuff with my friends I think
that played over what I'm extremely
casual but if Joe hold yeah I will be
swimming more of this maybe not more of
this but we'll be streaming more in
anything that comes up er forza horizon
or any of the other fours games you can
you bet we'll do it did you know going
back like 100 topics ago when we were
talking about monster trucks yeah did
you know that there's actually a
Saturday Night Live skit where it was um
it was supposed to be one of those a
monster truck commercial sunday sunday
sunday yeah but then it devolves into
this
commercial about monster trucks okay
building an agrarian society and then
moving to large urban centers were
trained and culture flourish that's an
actual commercial from Saturday night
Saturday Night Live I'm into it
also guys be nice to each other in the
chat I'll turn this whole stream around
I swear don't be mean to any of you
you're all my friends for the most part
some of you were kind of iffy but most
of you are yeah I'll see you too soon
maybe they'll let me on more stream
sometime oh yeah I mean you guys like
them I'm alright
Miguel's fantastic I can I can vouch for
that well yeah hello from Germany hello
from San Fran sunny South California
we've got a minute a singular minute so
I'm gonna do a cool promo out ladies and
gentlemen if you've enjoyed this stream
please be sure to follow and subscribe
so you don't miss a single video or a
live stream that we do coming up later
today we'll be doing a destiny
livestream with the the iron banner
stuff that they've got going on sure to
be a good time so make sure you don't
miss it
check out the lobby tomorrow we're going
to talk about some cool things be sure
to keep it keep it locked sorry I did
that and thanks for watching guys yeah
cuz it was a good time and once more one
last time I'm gonna say it I hope you
all have a very pleasant day this is 20
USD 20 $20 is 20 20 $20 great ready to
go me go yes okay bye everyone bye